Supreme Court heard opening arguments
yesterday about a case involving a man
who bakes cakes in Colorado and who did
not want to or made it based on his
religious beliefs make a cake for a
same-sex couple there went all the way
to the supreme in cake for the same-sex
couple my apologies
your take on the implications of this
case which will be heard now this case
really isn't even about freedom of
religion it really is just about freedom
of speech and freedom of association so
in this particular case the the Baker
not only was willing to make a cake for
the same-sex couple he was making
willing to make a cake for the wedding
he just wasn't willing to decorate it
with Pro same-sex marriages he also
won't decorate cakes for divorce cases
he won't decorate cakes for Halloween
for example this has nothing to do with
religion the question is in your
business are you allowed to decide how
you wish to use your skills and for
which events you wish to use your skills
the question that I'd asked to everyone
on the left whose opposes this Baker
this is really an act of tremendous
government tyranny yeah what I would ask
people on the left is let's say that you
are a Barack Obama acolyte you love the
guy and you write speeches one will tell
your speechwriter for President Obama
can I walk into your business tomorrow
and say I now need you to write speeches
for President Trump and it doesn't
matter if you don't like President Trump
the fact is I have an equal access to
your services and you should be able to
use your artistry for president Trump
otherwise you're discriminating if you
don't like that idea you shouldn't like
the idea of forcing a religious Baker to
violate his religious principles and
violate his free speech in order to
please you all right Ben Shapiro thanks
so much thank you Ben and thanks a lot